Let's go ahead and
create a new Android project and
then have a look at
the default build scripts.
We'll give our app a domain and
a location.
We'll set a main SDK and we'll add
a blank activity with a fragment.
We'll leave the defaults for
the fragment.
So here we are in our
newly created Android app.
If we go ahead and
haul out the ancient test device and
then run our application,
let's see what happens.
All right sweet,
looks like we're up and running.
So let's dive into what gradle
configuration is present by default.
Again the project pain has defaulted
to this Android centric setup.
But I find this kind of confusing so
I'm going to switch back to the project
to just show the straight
up project layout.
So here's our project and
here's our build.gradle file.
There's a whole lot going on in
the default Android build scripts.
For starters this is actually
a multi project build.
An Android app itself as a sub project.
We'll talk all about multi
project builds in lesson four but
it set up this way so it's easy to add
other sub projects that we want to
build together with the app like
libraries or even a backend.
There are two things to notice
in this route build script.
First we declare a build
script dependency
on com.android.tools.build:gradle:1.2.2.
There are two things to
note in this build script.
First, we declare a build script
dependency on this artifact coordinate.
This is where the Android plug in for
where gradle lives.
Second, and we'll talk about this
part of the gradle API soon.
But this block adds the jcenter
repository to every sub
project of this build.
That means every sub project can
just declare dependencies and
they'll automatically be
retrieved from jcenter.
Now let's take a look at
the build scripts specifically for
the android build.
Which is in the app directory.
So here's the build script for
the Android app.
Note that first applies the Android
plugin which it fetched from jcenter.
All configuration happens in
the Android configuration block.
All that's absolutely required are the
first two lines defining the SDK version
and the buildtoolsversion.
The default configured block, configures
attributes of the Android manifest.
We'll talk about the build
type’s block momentarily.
Finally the dependencies block
works just like java dependencies.
This declares the compile time
dependencies on every jar in the libs
directory and
on the Android support library.